they are fast becoming kovid hot spots
at these halls of residence in glasgow
600 students
are now self-isolating a major outbreak
has left at least 124 infected
although the uni says that number is
likely to be higher
one of those who tested positive is
isaac
it's not really exactly what anyone
wants for the first year of uni is it
like you want to go out you want to have
fun
and you want to enjoy it but it's just
it's an exception this year like
everyone's in the same boat and you
can't expect
you're the one exception to that rule
inside students are confined to their
accommodation
posters show who is having to
self-isolate
harriet and her friends live on the
ground floor
in the only flat with no cases it does
feel very dystopian having to wear a
mask when i leave my room to go to the
kitchen
and go to the bathroom things like that
especially because
i'm right on the end of the right in the
end of the corridor for our flat so
all the people around me across the
corridor next door to me all
have tested positive two miles away a
testing site has just been set up
at the murano street campus ben's just
had his
and tells me he's not surprised this has
happened just out here actually there's
a there's a large amount of people
gathering and stuff like that
and i think they just don't realize
realize it until it quite hits them
fresher's weak socializing is thought to
be behind
this coveted cluster outbreaks at
universities are perhaps no huge
surprise but the significant number of
confirmed cases and the large number of
students
having to self-isolate on campus is
becoming a real concern
for officials particularly over how
students may spread the virus
as the winter approaches there have also
been outbreaks at universities in dundee
edinburgh and liverpool it's leading to
suggestions
of christmas on campus with the
government not ruling out
having to tell students to stay at uni
this december
it's not inevitable that a very high
proportion of students have to stay in
their student accommodation but it will
become inevitable
if people uh break the rules a lot
between now and christmas
the latest campaign from the scottish
government a chilling reminder of how
easily covid can be passed on
the theory is universities are becoming
dangerous pockets of infection
which could spread far and wide dan
whitehead sky news
in glasgow